la journée continue à l'école beaucoup
d'avis divergents
le dossier du journal d'antenne de
hausse du taux d'intérêt de l'argent
explications et conseils de philippe
sassier la rentrée cinématographique le
point de vue de france roche mais
messieurs bonsoir ce soir encore david à
la une de ce journal le cyclone a
poursuivi aujourd'hui sa route infernale
et il a touché de plein fouet les îles
de la dominique et de la barbade au sud
des antilles 17 morts à la dominique et
à porto rico
les télégrammes alarmants se succèdent
dans deux heures il va fondre sur haïti
la capitale la dominique serait
pratiquement rasée et la martinique elle
même qui pourtant n'a été qu'effleuré
par le cyclone le plus violent du xxème
siècle où dit-on la martinique ce soir
panse ses plaies
laurent broomhead c'est l'heure du
premier bilan en martinique et en
guadeloupe pas de pertes de vies
humaines dans les îles françaises mais
des dégâts considérables
les bananeraies sont détruites à 100%
ainsi que la plupart des plantations
d'arbres fruitiers et de canne à sucre
les réseaux d'électricité de téléphone
sont endommagés environ 70%
il faudra sans doute plusieurs mois pour
les remettre en état ainsi que les
routes rendues inutilisables au nord et
à l'est de la martinique et dans l'île
de basse terre en guadeloupe
on dénombre au total 1000 sans abri mais
le drame est plus grave encore dans
l'île de la dominique totalement
dévastée sa capitale est terrassé 16
morts 60000 sans abri sur les 80000
habitants de cette petite île de 80
kilomètres carrés par ailleurs on
dénombre six morts et des centaines de
blessés à porto rico
david se rapproche maintenant d'haïti à
la vitesse de 20 km à l'heure tandis
qu'un autre site own frédéric le suit de
près frédéric devrait aborder la région
dimanche pour l'instant nettement moins
violent que david
il a toutefois tendance à gonfler et
comme il suit la même trajectoire
les spécialistes le guette heure par
heure en espérant qu'ils ne viennent pas
achever le travail destructeur de david
oui tout à l'heure le prenant un public
a fait savoir aux guadeloupéens et aux
martiniquais qu'ils suivaient leur
épreuve avec attention et émotion je le
cite paul dijoux sur socata d'état aux
dom tom sera chargé dû rendre compte de
l'ampleur des pertes subies et des
mesures à prendre
et puis son conseiller à l'elysée chargé
les dom-tom ira lui aussi sur place
monsieur jean baptiste est lui-même
antilles deuxième grands dossiers de
l'actualité ce soir la journée continue
dans les lycées c'est christian bilhac
le ministre de l'éducation qui hier a
dit aux jeunes giscardiens que les
expériences allait se poursuivre et même
se développer alors devant les réactions
à cette nouvelle tentative pour
améliorer les rythmes scolaires il a été
amené aujourd'hui à prendre un petit peu
de recul nous entendons tout à l'heure
ce qu'en dit son porte parole
mais quel que soit le sort réservé à ce
projet il y à là pensons-nous matière à
débat et nous voulons ouvrir ce débat
sur un thème de alors voici tout d'abord
un petit condensé des réactions des
principaux protagonistes dans cette
affaire
réactions recueillies par jean jacques
duffau la journée continue au lycée ce
n'est évidemment pas encore une
révolution dans les habitudes scolaires
françaises puisqu'il ne s'agit que d'une
possibilité d' expérience offerte aux
établissements du second cycle
mais enfin la proposition du ministre
c'est déjà un pas vers ce qui existe en
allemagne ou en angleterre
apparemment et bien qu'on ne puisse leur
donner une valeur de test national
les premières réactions semble négative
pour madame cabié mère de famille
l'inquiétude prédomine que pourront les
enfants la prévention est indispensable
de réformer les rythmes scolaires les
rythmes scolaires aujourd'hui ne
correspondent plus du tout à la vie en
1981 sadate 2100 1930 maintenant ça
risque de poser des problèmes aux mères
de famille personnellement je serais
très inquiète de savoir
mes enfants livrés à eux mêmes à partir
de 13 heures puisqu'il n'existe pas
d'équipements socio culturels ou
sportifs qu'ils soient leur disposition
donc je crois que en l'état ce serait
inquiétant pour les mais pour les
parents pour les fans à la difficulté
avancé manque d'infrastructures pierre
bru ce ton professeur de français à
reims en ajoute deux autres on nous
informe cette mesure tout dernier moment
et je dois dire qu'actuellement d'un
établissement la plupart des emplois du
temps la répartition d'occupation des
salles de classe est déjà terminé et je
ne vois donc pas les chefs
d'établissement refaire tout leur emploi
du temps
la deuxième raison c'est que je crois
qu'il n'y a pas les moyens matériels
pour assurer cette jolie continue dans
les instructions scolaire en particulier
je ferai à la cantine très rapidement
pour dire que on assiste à une réduction
des personnels alors qu'on devrait avoir
si cette mesure était mise en place un
afflux d'élèves et d'enseignants de
l'enseignant qui participent à quoi ça
peut paraître étonnant mais le fils et
la nièce de madame cabié ne sont pas
très enthousiastes ils pensent eux aussi
qu'il y a beaucoup de problèmes à
supprimer avant de transformer cette
expérience en réalité quotidienne
par contre il précise qu'il serait
s'occuper tout seul mais très capable de
s'occuper d'elle en tout cas à partir de
la seconde
mais ce que je pense que c'est un peu
ambitieux de se dire qu'on va être
capable de boucler les programmes en
quatre ou cinq heures par jour alors que
déjà en cette heure on a du mal à les
boucler alors si si on veut faire cette
réforme faut d'abord commencer par
raccourci coiffard changer les
programmes français parce qu'on a
beaucoup plus de travail que en
allemagne par exemple ou alors on a
parlé d' allemagne
ils ont beaucoup de travail connu et
vous oui mais je pense que
pas moi cette année par exemple j'avais
des journées complètes qui a les parents
de huit heures à 6 heures et demie au
moins deux et avec seulement une
après-midi de livres par semaine donc je
je me demande comment est ce que l'on
travaille en de 8h à 13h on pourrait
arriver à finir les programmes qui ne
sont pas toujours fini comme ça donc les
sages sont ce point de vue des du temps
il faudrait changer les programmes aussi
avec pour que la journée continue soit
un succès il faudrait aussi changer de
solides traditions alimentaires et
toutes les autres habitudes de vie bien
ancrée dans les mentalités celle des
élèves comme celle des enseignants ou
des parents
et puis il ya un interlocuteur qu'il ne
fallait je crois surtout pas oublier car
il a vraiment son mot à dire c'est le
médecin
le médecin chargé de suivre l'enfant et
bien contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait penser le praticien n'est pas
tellement favorable à un bouleversement
des rythmes scolaires
alors bien sûr les après midi seront
libres mais quelles charges pour les
matinées la journée continue pour les
lycéens ce sera à coup sûr davantage
d'après midi libre mais aussi davantage
de fatigue car les répercussions sur la
santé de cet aménagement du temps de
travail ne doit pas être sous-estimée
dans la mesure où l'on n'évoque à aucun
moment d'alléger parallèlement les
programmes or si ce rythme s'adapte bien
au travail de routine que fournit un
adulte il ne peut être sans risque quand
il s'agit de demander à des enfants ou à
des adolescents de fournir l'effort
particulièrement intense d'acquérir des
connaissances nouvelles
c'est pourquoi le docteur guy vermeille
qui s'intéressent au problème de la
fatique scolaires restent très
sceptiques
j'ai pas trop quoi en penser parce que
je pense que c'est une mesure isolée
et que si elle reste isolée elle va
aggraver une situation caractérisée par
le fait que les journées scolaires sont
trop chargés je souhaiterais que les
temps de travail des écoliers tout âge y
compris ceux des jeunes gens du
secondaire soit moins important chaque
jour quitte à diminuer le nombre de
jours de vacances et augmenter le nombre
de jours de classe annuel et je
désirerais que les intervalles de
travail soit mieux séparer soit plus
court qui des cours n'est pas une heure
mais trois quarts d'heure et qui d
intervalle alors si on
on établit une organisation de ce genre
là qui à mon avis apportera beaucoup
d'améliorations à ce moment là je suis
pas ennemi de la journée continue et je
pense que ce sera un progrès dans l'état
actuel des choses ce sera un progrès
pour certaines familles et certains
enfants
ce sera je crois dans l'ensemble bien
accueilli mais je crois qu'en réalité
cela représentera une cause de
diminution du rendement de la machine
scolaire est déjà très mauvais et une
augmentation de la fatigue de chaque
enfant puis bien sûr il ya aussi le
problème de savoir ce que feraient les
enfants de leur après-midi alors ayez le
sport mais certains peuvent se dire que
cela peut conduire à loisy fêter avec
évidemment tous les risques que cela
peut comporter alors cela dit on ne
raisonne pas dans le vide
on vous l'a dit il ya des expériences
dans de nombreux pays et dans certaines
institutions mêmes mises en place depuis
très longtemps c'est le cas pour nos
voisins allemands
un cas est étudié pour nous par
dominique laurens comme tous les
écoliers allemands rôle en très tôt le
chemin de l'école
il s'agit de ne pas être en retard le
premier cours commence à 8h précises
il y étudie jusqu'à 13h15 et la journée
scolaire et terminer l'après midi une
fois 7 voire achevé il sort avec sa mère
plein à la maison où se rend au club de
judo en allemagne fédérale le mi-temps
est appliqué dans toutes les écoles
jusqu'au baccalauréat
a priori on pourrait penser que les
jeunes allemands ont un programme moins
chargé que celui des élèves français
en fait si l'on totalise les heures de
travail sur une année des deux côtés du
rhin la différence est faible mais
l'application de ce système réclame
également une organisation stricte et
les horaires respectés à la lettre si
cours de 45 minutes dans une matinée
coupé par un repos de cinq minutes
parcours à ce que je sais les élèves
français surtout les jeunes élèves ont
un jour de congé pendant la semaine
tandis que les allemands vont à l'école
de lundi à samedi tous les matins cette
méthode on permet aux allemands de
travail et 27 heures par semaine
tout en étant libre l'après vente il est
utile de préciser que les jeunes france
totalise 28 heures par semaine dans le
primaire en sortant de l'école à 16h30
et 33 eur environ dans le secondaire en
quittant le lycée vers 17 principal
avantage les loisirs et notamment la
possibilité de pratiquer les sports deux
à trois heures par semaine en classe et
des compétitions l'après-midi les
avantages aussi il y en a libre l'après
midi les jeunes sont parfois livrés à
eux mêmes notamment dans les familles où
les mères travaillent mais ce système
est en fait peu contestée par l'epa cela
permet à la famille distille d'avoir
plus d'influencé sur les enfants que
leurs professeurs mais à nous disions le
ministère de l'éducation qui a
conscience d'avoir amorcé un joli sujet
à débat est aujourd'hui assez prudent
écoutez ce que disait d'antenne 2010 à
12h45 le recteur gauthier cette
expérience puisque expérience il y a on
doit recueillir les résultats les
analyses et que d'autre part elle
nécessite une organisation qui va faire
qu'on va consulter la totalité des
parties prenantes et parents d élèves
les enseignants et qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de difficultés pour
organiser une amie une journée continue
lesquels d'abord vermont ne peut pas
rassembler tout simplement la totalité
des cours dans un temps très court
sans penser à la fatigue des élèves et
par conséquent il faut prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions pour que
l'organisation des cours succession il y
a le transport scolaire qui aussi est
une contrainte les continue il y a
également les cantines il est vrai que
quand on aura la journée continue le
repas de midi par exemple devra être un
peu plus rapide
je pense que le petit déjeuner devrait
être le plus copieux ce sont des
habitudes a changé et vous voyez que
ceci implique une réflexion une
expérimentation et c'est l'objet de la
circulaire les journées continues existe
en allemagne et en angleterre et on peut
dire que les enfants s'en porte pas plus
mal alors est-ce que vous ne pouvez pas
étendre cette expérience au primaire et
au premier cycle
quand je dirais que la comparaison n'est
ce pas avec l'angleterre est avec
l'allemagne ne me paraît pas bonne parce
que il s'agit de mode de vie et de
systèmes très différents
c'est ce à quoi il nous faudra changer
nous mêmes notre système
si nous voulons la généraliser mais il
n'est pas question encore au niveau des
collèges et des lits et des écoles parce
que la pose un problème et en
particulier celui de la garde des
enfants
après leur libération très tôt dans
l'après midi que souvent cette
disposition dans les écoles et dans les
collèges ne s'appliquerait qu'avec une
modification de la vie de l'ensemble de
la cité deux informations maintenant qui
concerne encore notre vie pratique tout
d'abord l'interdiction du cumul des
livrets à des caisses d'épargné de ceux
du crédit mutuel ce qu'on appelle le
livret bleu donc plus de cumul entre ces
deux livrets ce sera l'un ou l'autre
et puis à destination de ceux qui
veulent emprunter de l'argent pour
acheter un appartement ou bien le
terrain cette grosse augmentation des
taux d'intérêt ces derniers temps des
taux d'intérêt qui ne sont pas uniformes
selon les banques contrairement à ce que
l'on croit philippe sassier oui d'abord
une faut dire qu'on assiste actuellement
une forte hausse du prix de l'argent sur
le marché monétaire la ou les banque
viennent faire leur marché en quelque
sorte c'est à dire emprunter de l'argent
qu'elle reprenne seront ensuite cette
hausse des taux d'intérêt est vrai en
angleterre est vrai aux états unis est
vrai en allemagne alors en france vivent
ou depuis le début d'année depuis le
mois de mars
ce prix de l'argent a fortement monté 6%
mars 9% en juillet et 10 et demi pour
cent en août alors ça c'est ce que
payent les banques qui viennent d'être
large allant mais alors ça sert et perla
d'été ça va se répercuter ça commence
déjà à se répercuter sur le crédit que
l'on peut demander pour acheter une
voiture ou un appartement alors j'ai
essayé cet après-midi d'emprunter de
l'argent une forte somme volontairement
pour bien souligner la con par exemple
sur 15 ans pour acheter un appartement
un établissement me proposer
2 75% et j'aurais rembourser pendant 15
ans 3400 francs par mois un autre
établissement nous proposait 14 30%
j'aurais rembourser 4000 francs par mois
toujours pendant 15 ans une différence
de 600 francs par mois voyez-vous cela
vaut la peine de bien comparer et ses
3000 dit en exprimant important de
connaître les adresses entre les deux
côtés pad adresse enfin des conseils si
l'on veut emprunter de l'argent
aujourd'hui dans une période
effectivement de hausse des taux
d'intérêt à 1 il faut faire le tour des
différents établissements caisse
d'epargne banque crédit mutuel est
véritablement les mettre en concurrence
deuxièmement demander si tous les frais
sont bien compris les frais d'assurance
et frais de dossiers etc
troisièmement demandé sur le taux
d'intérêt est indexé au taux d'escompté
par exemple dans de savoir si cette
somme de remboursement va varier dans
les années qui gagne enfin quatrièmement
il faut surtout bien comparer non pas
tellement les taux d'intérêt mais la
somme que chaque mois au lavoir à
rembourser c'est la seule façon de bien
choisir l'organisme à tout vendre un
crédit voilà un mot sur la politique
pour évoquer deux sondages publiés par
deux hebdomadaires de fin de semaine
l'express et le nouvel observateur pour
l'express un jugement sévère sur le
gouvernement dit l'institut louis harris
france pour 62% des français raymond
barre a échoué matignon 39% estiment
qu'un gouvernement de gauche ne ferait
pas mieux
27% mieux et 19% - bien sondage
complémentaires effectués par la sofres
pour le nouvel observateur 68% des
français estiment que le gouvernement
face à la crise ne sait pas où il va et
les trois quarts pensent que les
salariés sont prêts à faire grève ou à
manifester nucléaire je vous signalais
hier l'incident de three mile island aux
états unis bien une faute qui a ajouté
un accident en france beaucoup moins
grave heureusement à la centrale de
bugey une fuite d'effluents faiblement
radioactifs mais sans contamination des
personnels ces effluents tous été
récupérés et les systèmes de sécurité
ont bien fonctionné dit la cgt
je crois que c'est l'occasion pour nous
de vous présenter jugé deuxième centrale
nucléaire au monde
cette tour 227 mètres de haut c'est une
des quatre tours de réfrigération de la
centrale du bugey
lorsque celle-ci fonctionnera à plein
régime elle produira 4150 mégawatts ou
10% de la production électrique
française
cinq réacteurs fourniront l'énergie
nécessaire à cette production un de la
filière française à uranium naturel ici
au premier plan et quatre de la filière
pwr américaine à uranium enrichi c'est
dans le réacteur numéro 4 que la fuite
s'est produite et plus exactement sur
une des trois pompes primaires dès que
la fuite a commencé tous les systèmes de
sécurité ont parfaitement fonctionné il
faut dire que cette centrale possède un
simulateur où tous les opérateurs de
france viennent justement s'entraîner en
particulier pour apprendre à réagir au
mieux et au plus vite en cas d'incident
ou de panne
c'est peut-être la raison pour laquelle
les habitants des alentours ne semble
pas inquiet ça vous gêne pas d'être à
côté d'une centrale comme ça au
personnellement - non mais la handicape
le handicap c'est que ses propres buts
rail pas pourquoi avec tout plein
d'autres tensions il passe devant
gottéron avec les régulations que c'est
gênant contournement pour par une juge
appelle ça pète ça risque orias elle est
utile automatiquement puisque produit du
jeu remarquez que c'est un type épaule
avant pour l'étranger aussi fort
les dirigeants de la centrale estime
qu'il faudra une quinzaine de jours pour
les travaux de remise en état des joints
qui ont provoqué la fuite ce qui fait
qu'actuellement tous les réacteurs de
bugey sont arrêtés compte tenu de
quelques incidents et de vérification
sur les différentes tranches pour éviter
d'avoir à les faire cet hiver la
centrale ne fournira sa pleine puissance
qu'au mois de novembre et non en octobre
comme c'était prévu
un retard qui s'explique aussi par les
précautions prises par edf pour éviter
des accidents qui serait plus fâcheux
qu'un simple retard de production
d'électricité les affaires du monde
maintenant avec tout d'abord ce nouveau
rebondissement au proche orient les
contacts reconnu par moshe dyan le
ministre israélienne est étrangère avec
des notables proche de l'eau ltée et le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que ces
contacts suscite des remous à jérusalem
est moche et dejan je croyais vraiment
un spécialiste un habitué des petites
bombes
jean landry oui monsieur mouche et diana
d'or se placer à contre-courant quitte
d'ailleurs à rentrer ensuite assez
rapidement dans le rang donc qu'il dit
et bien puisque nous devons donner
l'autonomie aux palestiniens devraient
peut-être savoir ce que les palestiniens
pensent ils pour savoir ce qu'ils
pensent surtout même parlé avec eux et
c'est pour ça que j'ai rencontré
effectivement anota palestinien très
proche de l'ol paie et je les rencontre
et lui dit il sans prévenir monsieur
begins alors ya une espèce de tempête
politique et plusieurs membres du
gouvernement disent qu'ils vont demander
des explications à leur collègue le
ministre des affaires étrangères jeudi
boussaïna mal pris la chose que vous
avez ya pas que monsieur ryan qui voit
des gens on va vous remarquer
aujourd'hui par exemple que monsieur
begin recevait un très mystérieux
émissaire roumains et on s'est souvenu
que le président ou même chercher ce
coup aimé jouer les intermédiaires entre
arabes et israéliens est ce qu'on peut
dire enfin c'est que toutes les têtes
politiques d'israël essaye de trouver
une solution pour sortir un peu de cette
espèce d'impasse diplomatique où israël
riche actuellement tu trouvé enfermé et
puis faut relier sa à la ferme young et
sachets à ce propos que c'est son
adjoint qui lui succède finalement le nu
comme représentant permanent se
maquiller et lui aussi de race noire il
a 42 ans dernières informations en
provenance de cette région du monde
les préliminaires du sommet des
non-alignés avec déjà une première
rencontre plutôt fraîches entre fidel
castro puissance invitante et le
maréchal tito chef historique du
mouvement des non-alignés
ils se rencontrent ils se parlent mais
ils ne se comprennent pas le maréchal
tito 87 ans et fidel castro essais avant
la conférence des non alignés qui
s'ouvre lundi à l'avant de dégager une
position commune acceptable pour les 95
états membres mais quelle position
le leader yougoslave et pour un non
alignement véritable pour une politique
qui ne serait à la remorque ni de moscou
lit de washington le numéro un cubain au
contraire pensent que les pays du
tiers-monde se doivent de rester très
proche des positions soviétique donc pas
d'accord de fonds possible à la havane
tout au plus d'émotions de compromis
puisque nous parlons de la vanne une
dépêche vient de tomber il ya une
demi-heure de presse est une révélation
du gouvernement américain qui
confirmeraient la présence d'une brigade
soviétique de 2 à 3000 hommes armés à
tuba le gouvernement cubain des mains
mais le gouvernement américain confirme
tout aussi officiellement pour le
gouvernement américain il y à une
brigade de combat soviétique
deux à trois mille hommes à cuba c'est à
dire 150 km des côtes américaines et
vous souvenez que la dernière grande
crise est-ouest en 1962 ça a été
précisément le fait que les soviétiques
avaient installé des fusées à cuba et
c'est vraiment la dernière fois où le
monde à trembler ou le vent dans la baie
des cochons
tout le monde a eu peur vraiment d'une
guerre atomique alors bon une brigade de
combat de 3000 hommes c'est moins grave
que diffuser et qui pourrait emporter
des charges nucléaires sur l'amérique si
proche mais est ce que le président
carter peut se permettre d'être moins
ferme que monsieur kennedy l'avait été
en 1962 vous savez on a l'impression que
cette affaire de la danseuse savez la
ferme la sauva n'a été que la
manifestation tout à fait épidermique de
quelque chose de plus grave d'une
tension que grave et plus sérieuses
entre les états unis et l'urss qui est
en train de monter et pour l'instant
washington minimise un petit peu le
risque que cela représenterait pour les
états unis
enfin on prend date argentine maintenant
les espoirs s'amenuisent de retrouver ce
que l'on appelait pudiquement des
disparus le gouvernement militaire de
buenos aires viennent en effet de
publier une nouvelle loi qui considère
que toute personne disparue depuis un an
sera automatiquement considéré comme
décédé
le gouvernement argentin entend ainsi se
dégager de toute responsabilité dans les
disparitions
je rappelle que treize français sont
encore portés disparus
cantine depuis deux ans parfois plus ces
familles attendent en vain des nouvelles
d'un fils d'un frère d'une soeur ou d'un
père mystérieusement disparu en
argentine la loi que vient de publier le
gouvernement militaire leur laisse un
peu moins d'espoir de les retrouver
vivants
elle prévoit en effet que toute personne
disparue qui ne donnera pas de ses
nouvelles sera considéré comme décédé
une façon pour le régime du général
videla de dégager ses responsabilités
dans les enlèvements commis dit on par
ces polices parallèles
vingt mille personnes des argentins et
des étrangers sont encore portées
disparues
parmi elles 13 français aucune nouvelle
depuis des mois sauf pour trois d'entre
eux comme françoise dauthier par exemple
on sait qu'elle était vivante il y a
moins d'un an
ou encore ils domergue disparu en 76 à
rosario
mais la loi sur les disparus laisse peu
d'espoir à sa famille qui l'a accueilli
avec effroi avec effroi et désespoir
parce que cette nouvelle loi permet au
gouvernement argentin d'assassiner
légalement tous les disparus qui ne le
sont pas encore tous les disparus qui
peuvent être encore en vie dans un camp
pouvant être assassiné étant donné que
ils ne pourront sûrement pas se
présenter aux convocations du ministère
de la justice ou du juge donc ces
personnes seront déclarées mortes
légalement à ce moment là le
gouvernement peut les abattre
tranquillement ce que ressent pas le
tout en prenant tout son temps et sans
aucun problème donc pour vous cela
signifierait l'élimination physique des
quelques 20 mille disparus qui de ceux
qui restent encore vivants parce que des
vingt mille disparus on a peu d'espoir
qui on est plus que 500 à 700
actuellement encore vivant voilà
maintenant trois ans que votre fils est
disparu quelles sont les nouvelles que
vous avez pu avoir les témoignages que
vous avez pu obtenir en trois ans
presque rien rien un silence total
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours j'ai pu
avoir une information très importante
d'abord sur la date exacte de sa
disparition
avant je vous disais toujours 7 en
septembre 1976 maintenant je sais que
c'est le 26 septembre 1976 et qu'en plus
il n'était pas seul il est accompagné de
sa fiancée et 2e renseignements encore
plus important yves était vivant en
septembre 1978 dans une prison
officielle argentine mais sans être
enregistrées sur les livres de registre
d'entrée c'est un témoignage sur que
vous avez pu vous tapez sur pour les
parents deal domergue pour des milliers
d'autres aussi l'espoir c'est une date
le 6 septembre prochain jour du voyage
d'une mission d' enquête interne
américaine sur les droits de l'homme en
argentine enfin sachez que le président
giscard d'estaing était aujourd'hui
l'hôte à déjeuner du président
sénégalais léopold sédar senghor dans sa
propriété que celui ci possède deux dans
le calvados déjeuner en tête à tête tout
à fait pris l'information générale de
télégrammes tout d'abord qui je crois se
passe de commentaires même s'ils sont
bien navrant pour le corps le
cambriolage du domicile de marie marqué
aujourd'hui les voleurs n'ont pas hésité
à monter sur le lit où reposait le corps
de l'actrice qui doit être inhumé
vendredi prochain pour fouiller les
placards et emporter argent et bijoux
et puis à verdun une femme de 69 ans a
été humilié puis torturé chez elle par
quatre voyous le plus jeune a 12 ans le
plus âgé 18
hervé de vathaire est libre c'est lui
qui avait demandé qui avait emprunté
entre guillemets 8 millions de francs à
son patron marcel dassault
il avait été condamné à quatre ans de
prison ils y allaient être mis en
liberté conditionnelle justice toujours
le leader d'extrême-gauche italien
piperno ne sera pas extradé
la cour d'appel de paris a dit non à la
demande formulée par les autorités
italiennes dans le domaine maintenant
des curiosités se fait rarissime la
naissance de triplés au domicile d'une
vache cela s'est passé à rimont en
gironde
les trois veaux se porte bien la maman
aussi selon notre spécialiste philippe
dumais denjean de naissance si l'un
dévoué du sexe féminin il est
automatiquement stérile voilà sport vous
l'avez vu je crois dans notre journal de
12h45 patrick de taille et le pilote de
l'écurie ligier est sortie aujourd'hui
de cliniques qu'il avait été victime
d'un accident de deltaplane il ya trois
mois il ne pourra parcourir avant au
moins un mois
et puis tennis avec eux tout d'abord
cette très bonne surprise qui nous vient
de flushing meadow c'est à dire du
tournoi américain
le français yannick noah a réussi à
battre en trois sets secs
le polonais fiba qui est l'un des
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux 6 4 6 4 7 6
il se qualifie ainsi pour le troisième
tour de ce tournoi nous console en de
certains déboires français puis
l'américain john mcenroe a battu le
roumain ilie nastase en quatre sets au
cours de cette partie de nombreuses
interruptions dues vous l'imaginez
facilement aux discussions interminables
du roumain
l'une d'elles a parait-il du à 19
minutes
notre page cinéma maintenant avec la
grande reprise de l'activité sur les
écrans il était temps car si le premier
semestre a été bon la fréquentation des
salles a baissé de 10% au mois d'août
par rapport à l'année dernière
la semaine qui vient de s'écouler se
présente mieux et les films à venir
devrait aider encore davantage le
mouvement
au programme des films comiques mais
également d'action avec france rachel
aperçu de ses films le film qui a battu
les records de recettes en amérique cet
été aliens est un film d'action à la
fois à science fiction et horreur me
guerre des étoiles me jaws en être venu
de l'espace tu tour à tour les sept
habitants d'un cargo spatial
le seul survivant et oui une femme
cette saab limité de la belle et la bête
est un féru relais car sa perfection
technique décourage les fous rires
déclenché généralement par les films
spatiaux style bazar une révélation
sigourney weaver une sorte de jane fonda
plus athlétique
sortie 12 septembre en deux semaines de
rentrer 25 nouveau film avec quatorze
grandes vedettes prédominance des héros
comique avec ugo tognazzi dans le
fouineur peter falck dans ne tirez pas
sur le dentiste jean wilder dans un
rabbin au far west le premier western
lydie show indien et michel serrault
dans l'associé picollier dutronc dans le
mort aux dents satire sociale et encore
satire sociale avec arrow papa dont la
vedette et vittorio gassman ce film a
valu au jeune stéphane aux médias son
partenaire appris à cannes d'américains
film de jack nicholson mettre en scène
avec nicholson vedette you going staff
et puis le syndrome chinois film à
suspense où le vilain et l'atome le
bonheur jane fonda la révélation jack
lemmon dans un rôle dramatique qui lui a
valu le premier prix à cannes le 19 la
vague festival continue avec les deux
palmes d'or de mai dernier le tambour de
volker schlondorff on découvre un enfant
étrange david bennent et apocalypse now
de francis ford coppola avec marlon
brando mais la vraie vedette c'est la
guerre du vietnam
pour finir sur une note tout plutôt sur
des notes plus douce voici folli follie
parodie du film américain musicale
d'entre les deux guerres
il sera présenté dimanche en ouverture
du festival du film américain à
deauville metteur en scène stanley donen
oui
paris
enfin m
c'est maintenant la météo sociale s'est
bien passé aujourd'hui quelques nuages
ont quand même planer sur la bretagne et
sur la moitié est du pays les quelques
aura alors pour demain et bien pour
demain le temps sera chaud sur la plus
grande partie de la france mais le ciel
deviendra plus nuageux sur la bretagne
et le bassin parisien de la loire aux
pyrénées mais surtout en aquitaine
quelques risques d'orages bernard
pradines au vous fixent rendez-vous à
22h40 pour le dernier journal de la
journée demain samedi ennemi sera
présentée par noël mamère une émission
consacrée à la défense du littoral
toujours demain mai à 20h léon zitrone
qui retrouvera ses habitudes de fin de
semaine tous les samedis et tous les
dimanches pour je l'espère votre plus
grand plaisir
et puis enfin dans un peu moins d'une
heure un petit événement sur notre
chaîne le 200ème numéro d' apostrophes
barbares qui vous vous êtes avec nous
sur ce plateau
c'est devenu une institution c'est pas
tellement votre gens ça vous gêne un peu
200ème numéro dont une institution dit
l'académie française c'est telle
institution mais elle a été créée sous
richelieu alors qu'elle postroff n'était
est créée par marcel julien qui n'est
pas que je sache un contemporain de de
richelieu choix qu'on peut dire sur la
chaîne par exemple des émissions comme
des chiffres et des lettres ou une
hausse et les grands sont des
restitutions ces émissions ont été
puisées au moins sous zèle cinq ou six
présidents tandis que moi je n'en suis
qu'à mon second bon alors vous faites
partie avec moi avec tous les camarades
du journal de 2 ce que régis debray
dénonce un petit peu quand il s'en prend
aux pouvoirs intellectualité vrai que
vous êtes en situation de monopole camp
quand vous essayez de faire aimer les
livres français
on ne peut pas me reprocher de faire
aimer les livres français et faire lire
c'est d'ailleurs une tâche qui est prévu
par le cahier des charges et c'est la
tâche que m'a confié la direction de
cette chaîne donc effectivement j'essaye
de faire rire les français
j'essaye de le mieux possible en
invitant des gens que non je pense
qu'ils ont écrits d'excellents les vous
avez conscience d'être de monsieur la
littérature en france l'homme que guette
tous les libraires toutes les attachés
de presse les maisons d'édition l'homme
par qui tout peut marcher ou tomber non
je suis pas celui par qui tout peut
marcher double tombé il ya effectivement
apostrophe à lancer des best-sellers
comme aussi divers par exemple que
fragments d'un discours amoureux de
roland barthes ou bien la bimbo de basse
non la soupe aux airs d'emily carr loup
vous la paille et le grain de françois
mitterrand je pense était bientôt mais
la déliquescence du les best-sellers et
dont les auteurs n'ont pas été invités
un peu strophe
je compte donner un exemple très récent
c'est le livre de samuel d'isère ces
questions que je n'aime pas ce livre je
ne vais pas invité le l'auteur à mon
émission
vous avez de bons sondages moins bon
indice des coûts comme on dit entre nous
il n'y a pas un risque celui de
développer une culture de drogue store
un petit peu de supermarché bah si vous
appelez culture de rockster les gens que
j'ai invité dans une heure c'est à dire
si romancier qui seront certainement
course pour les plus littéraires et bien
les dogues rockster vont faire
concurrence bientôt l'académie française
et l'académie goncourt
j'ai laissé notre camarade speakerine
dire précisément quels sont vos invités
donc tout à l'heure vers 21h40
comme d'habitude puisque nous avons
encore un peu débordés je vous souhaite
une très très bonne soirée une très
bonne fin de semaine aussi et puis
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
lundi ce lundi soir 20h au revoir à tous
à